RANGERS.
>> Joe: IT MAKES YOU THINK OF A
21-YEAR-OLD LAST EIGHT.
A COUPLE OF LONOUBA WAS STOPPED.
HERE IS
THEY HAVE GIVEN UNFORTUNATE>> JE
TOO ROUGH.
A LITTLE WRIST SHOT.
LOOKED LIKE ZIBANEJAD GOT A BOQ.
TROUBA LOOKING FOR AN OPENING.
VESEY ABLE TONE.
20 FEET OUT FROM HIM OR SO.
THE DEFLECTION.
LOOK
SUDDENLY, EVERYTHING OPENED UP
HISCHIER COMING UP.
HE FAKES LIKE HJOHNSSON.
RANGERS TRY TUTIFUL
PASS.
HE HAS TO FLIP IT UP IN THE AIR
AND TRYING TO GET IT TO LAND
FLAT. PLAYER.
GOOD FOR THE ABOUT SECOND PERIO
>> Sam: PANARIN
THAT WAS A FALLS BEHIND, STICK
ON THE ICE.
PERFECT LITTLE DROP PASS AND
CH SCHNEIDER.HE ICE.
BOQVIST
SAVE.
SHESTERKIN HOLDS IT.
BARRON IS S
PERIOD BUT
SIEGENTHALER IS
MADISON SQUARE GARDEN FOR  THIS.
BRATT HAD A CHANCE MAKE A DEFENE
AND FORGET ABOUT THE HISCHIER A
CAN DO WITH A LIT BY
TROUBA.
>> Joe: WHAT A BIG-TIME PLAY B
THEN MILLER ACTUALLY DEFLECTED A
SHOT.
SHARANGOVICH WITH THE PUCK.
RANGERS HAD A GOOD SHORTHANDED
CHANCECE
HERE.
COMING IN ERS HIS THING  IT OUT.
NI, ACTUALLY.
THE SECOND ONE YOU MENTIONED H H
WHAT A SHOT BY CHRIS KREIDERER S